ASAP rocky very very famous rapper he
was in Sweden and then the first veto
came out looks like him and his crew
were beating up these two guys alright
so I'll show you a little bit of this
first
I'm a ASAP Rocky fan yeah he does
everything I'm also up to you or I think
so you'll see right around here they're
beating up these guys alright this is
actually sad rocky tossing this dude
damn he tossed the [ __ ] I mean that
is punching him there this is in Sweden
yeah yeah but what were those guys doing
yeah so the ASAP Steam released their
own video of what how this even started
and it's these guys constantly berate
him like just following them and just
annoying them they like call him the
n-word or no they just it seems like you
just saw drugs or something
turn it up
oh they said we don't want any problem
and you guys just keep following him
keep following them and then they
actually this dude the one that's the
closest he throws his headphones at the
bodyguard this wide like real thing so
you'll have to have bodyguards this is
this oh wow so this guy's trying to hit
the bodyguard throws his headphones out
him see it [ __ ] that dummy up you want a
piece of [ __ ] again he's like that
bodyguards cool
what's that little dude think it's gonna
happen so he's trying to de-escalate the
situation is that a surprise I said oh
wow because you hit him with your
headphones
these guys are Turkish and these guys
are fans of ASAP I don't know that's
Swedish these guys are EMA growl the
elder yeah they're immigrants they're
said they're from somewhere in the
Middle East I think I don't know what's
going on or why they're this right with
this and they just won't leave the boat
leave them alone and then some other
witnesses come by that speak their
language and tell Muhammad something so
they're following the bodyguard right
now we're dudes man people are [ __ ]
weird and then he walks back and the
guys still come out I'm again so these
are women are the ones that translate
for them to meet we're our bodyguards
out of shape
he's just caught him on his head
those girls are Somali I think Utah
these guys are talking shimmy earlier
thought through the headphones we think
that is even you can't I can't you can't
do that dude
yes I can no you can't do you'd be sued
up the yin-yang that's why you pay
bodyguards so he's a proc you shouldn't
got involved it'd be tough not to though
tough not to just a [ __ ] punch Manila
hardest especially in international
territory so that last guy there's no
witness he goes that those guys one of
them slapped my ass and my girlfriend's
ass last time so they're troublemakers
for sure all right
and now because of this this is a [ __ ]
ASAP Rocky's in jail and the hell they
like they're gonna hold on for two weeks
you're supposed to hold for three days
max but they're all in for two weeks
that is so frustrating and it's
apparently they said there's rumors that
it's a really really crappy situation
there the but his lawyers saying is not
that bad but still he's held there
that's so part of his team's held there
too even if you want to get put in jail
sweet yeah and that's so jacked up but
he's in jail with a lot of people from
not from Sweden yes so sweet so so so
Sweden took in a lot of immigrants from
the Middle East they said prime try his
best signs or not doing he's in jail and
not the other guy the guys nine jail did
you see the guy [ __ ] with Ben Askren
no you didn't see the drunk fan [ __ ]
with Ben asked me before his fight no
trying trying to eat start like oh [ __ ]
that's kind of stuff let's end on this
one that's kind of stuff is so
exhausting this [ __ ] makes me want to
take those Dudesons Oh what do you say
those heads where do you see this look
at this guy
[Applause]
[Music]
this dude exhausting exhausting
he just wants to poke a bear and see
what it's like one quick last thing
imagine beat us right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]